The Joe Rogan Experience yeah I I um I
enjoyed The Gray Man movie but it was
not as good as your book thank you for
saying that it just wasn't the same
story yeah like they they they
hollywoodized it absolutely and you know
I liked it and and what I say and I
don't know how this makes me sound it's
like the movie is the best possible
commercial for my writing and if you're
a writer you want eyeballs on your work
and so it's I love the movie and you
know there's bits of dialogue in there
and things they did with the plot that
that I really liked but you know it's
not as gritty it's not um not nearly
yeah you know and they do things that
they have to do shorthand in a in a
movie I get a hundred thousand words to
write a book or 150 000 words to write a
book so um I have some luxuries that you
know they don't have putting something
on the screen but I like the fact that
they're different in to the because
there's still a reason to read my book
did you saw the movie and enjoyed it
hopefully it turns you on to the book
and and then you see some something
different in there no I definitely think
there's that element to it because it is
it's a it's for sure a hollywoodized
version of these gritty books that you
write yeah but it's also good yeah like
if you didn't know about the book yeah
you just saw the movie it's good yeah
different things but the bug is so much
[__] nastier and also I said thank
you I don't know if that's what I should
say
but court Gentry in your books is just
so much different than Ryan in the
movies it's just like yeah I mean they
did a lot without dialogue which I
appreciated and I liked you know you
know he'd do a lot with a look but I
mean when you in a book you're able to
get into the character's head quite a
bit quite a bit more so it's a different
experience if you could pick a person
like an actor if you could start from
scratch no disrespect to it's Ryan
Reynolds or right got Gosling yeah yeah
why do I always [__] that up I always
[__] that up
I couldn't pick either one of them out
of a [__] lineup to save my life
Gosling Ryan Gosling I really like the
guy too yeah by the way
um
who would you pick if you want if you
know just like if you could just like
say any actor like who who do you think
you would go with you know that's it's a
tough question because that thing has
been in Hollywood the gray man's been in
Hollywood since two months before the
little paperback came out in 2009 so
it's been bouncing around and I've heard
every actor at one point Brad Pitt was
signed on to it and really yeah yeah
like back 2011 or something and then it
fell apart and it came back and each
time they would send me a script or
whoever was doing it and at one point
Charlie's Darren wanted to do it and
they rewrite yeah she wanted to be the
girl no she wanted to be Court Gentry oh
my God so they they wrote a script for
it and it was good screenwriters and I
remember reading the script going like
was it the gray woman or the gray
non-binary person it was still The Gray
Man her name was still Court Gentry but
everyone everything was different then
they never really explained is that
short for Courtney or something oh my
god um but it was just a completely
different plot and thank God they didn't
do that I thought if they changed you
know like if and I love her because she
just done Fury Road so I mean I'd love
to write something for her to be in I
didn't see Fury Road oh the Mad Max oh
oh man Max yeah okay
um and she was so good but as an author
you couldn't put out the gray man novel
with her face on it and they opened the
book and it has nothing to do
um you know with a woman and and as much
as I love her like I was like well this
isn't gonna you know sell books or get
eyes in my work this green play was
actually really good but I remember
thinking if I went to the theater and
saw it and had a different title I would
not even know there'd be like one scene
where I'm like oh yeah I did a thing on
a plane too you know it was so different
it was a completely different plot it
was good I wish they'd make it and call
it something else yeah make it and call
it something else you don't call it the
gray man it's that's such a weird Choice
yeah yeah at one point like real early
on when it first got optioned people are
asking me who should play the character
and I thought it would be somebody who's
not like you know Rambo or anything like
that so I was saying like Casey Affleck
or somebody like that oh interesting you
wouldn't expect uh you know in a big
action film but wouldn't you need
someone who's like physically formidable
yeah you know I don't the thing is is
I've written 12 books and I've never
once had him working out I've never
shown anymore no I've never shown him
working out you know or even really
training because you talked a couple of
times about him doing like calisthenics
or something oh yeah yeah I've thrown it
in a little bit because I'm like all
right how how does this possibly happen
right how does he keep these perishable
skills yeah and his Fitness up but you
know there's there's actors that like I
really like like Max Martini I don't
know if you know that is
um you know him if you saw him he's he
he was in 13 hours it was a really good
movie and um Michael Bay film wow look
at that that's amazing
um and so he's you know he's like a
formidable dude and a really good actor
but there's you know he doesn't
I like the physical presence of him yeah
he might be good too because even though
he's kind of recognizable it's not Brad
Pitt like right every time Brad Pitt's
in a movie it's Brad Pitt if that guy's
in a movie you could say oh I think I've
seen that guy in something before but
but he's Court Gentry yeah exactly well
I got a ton of people mad that Ryan
Gosling was in it before it came out and
they were like you need to get some
unknown guy because nobody recognizes it
and I'm like you probably don't
understand how 200 million dollar movies
work they don't what we're going to do
is we're gonna get this guy out and you
know find the guy at the mall and make
him the you know is this just not how it
works it's too bad because I I don't
really know if it makes a difference I
think they think it makes a difference
but I think if you have a movie that has
an amazing plot and a great like trailer
and it looks wild and like people I
think people get sucked into it anyway
yeah and and honestly like one of the
best films I've ever seen in my life
which is an action film it's a Korean
film called The Man from Nowhere and
it's also and fortunately it came out
after the gray men did otherwise people
would think I'd ripped off the gray man
because it's about a a former assassin
who's trying to lay low and he ends up
having to rescue this girl well the book
though came so much earlier than the
movie like how many years was it between
you writing the book and then the film
coming out I wrote the book in 2007 it
came out in 09 and it and the film came
out in 22 and so it's like 14 years I
was still lucky you know everybody's
like I bet you hate that you had to wait
this long and I'm like if you know if I
was an 85 year old man and they and they
made a film out of one of my books I'd
be thrilled so yeah it's a it's a rare
thing right so especially a big
Blockbuster film with Ryan Gosling
you're getting this one
there it is there we go Chris Evans is
great in that too yeah he was terrific
yeah he he really played an awesome
version of the character you wrote In
the book yeah and that's a that's an
example of a difference in the film that
I that I liked you know because my Lloyd
in in the book is not like a physical
presence he's more of like the [__]
Master Mastermind of the whole thing
right but I mean obviously if they can
get Chris Evans in their film they're
going to beef up his role and and make
it a more monoi mono thing and and I
thought that was fabulous yeah and Chris
Evans just really nailed it he played
the perfect douchebag [__] cocky
confident psychopath yeah it looked like
he was having fun yeah yeah yeah it was
great it was great I wasn't closely
involved with it I went out and met the
Russo brothers when they were going to
write the script and spend a few days
with them talking about the story and
where the future story because they
wanted to be a French franchise from the
beginning but I wasn't involved in the
day-to-day but I was sent in Scripts Joe
sent me the script that he wrote and
then I saw the the shooting script like
right when they were shooting so that
was my involvement with it and then I
would be on Twitter and I'd see Ryan
Gosling dressed up as a gray man on
Twitter you know I didn't see it any way
any anybody else would have seen it you
know are they doing a series are they
going to continue they're doing a second
one yeah yeah and they're right and
they're writing a spin-off series which
I know nothing about but the guy who
wrote uh Deadpool uh Rhett Reese I think
they're writing a spin-off based on who
someone in the series and I really don't
know I'm not being cagey it's really
yeah yeah I just know that that's
happening that's even weirder so now
someone's like taking your world and
it's almost like the Spider-Man thing
yeah I mean it depends on what they do
if they take a character that like uh
Zoya who's this Russian former Russian
um foreign intelligence I love that
character thank you thanks um you know
if they did something with her that
would be cool if they did something with
Zach Hightower who's kind of like his on
and off against sidekick you know that
would be cool but I I don't know what it
is but they are doing a sequel with Ryan
Gosling
um in the role have they started that
yeah they're writing the script
um or Steve mcfeely is writing the
script one of the screenwriters on Gray
Man and is it based on any of your books
it's going to be based on one of the
books which books no I don't know that I
I didn't ask if you're allowed and
that's permission I get it my whole
point in coming here today was to walk
out of here and not go oh my God what I
can't believe I just said that
was pretty far that was close well you
know oh you did a good job you navigated
it it's um is it a weird thing to watch
someone change your script and to change
the plot and change how the characters
interact and it is really weird I think
I went into it with the right mindset
that you know this was a represent a
film representation and I know that the
directors are like really creative
people and the screenwriters and
cinematographers and actors and they
don't look at it as their job that
they're Engineers that are going to take
a piece of paper and turn it into
Celluloid with everyone doing exactly
the same thing so I never expected that
there are places in there where I think
I like I really like what they did and
there's places in there where it's like
I think my line landed a little bit
better you know like and and that
actually made me happy it I wasn't mad
that like they didn't do it my way it's
more like okay I think I have something
to offer still instead of you know all
these big shots with all this money come
and make something so like
you know vastly superior to the little
paperback that I wrote you know it's
like I think there's places where my
stuff holds up and there's stuff in
there that I think is fantastic too but
it is really strange the toughest thing
is the complaints from fans that aren't
happy because of the changes so yeah
people just pigeonhole me all the time
at a conference or something and they'll
be like in the movie they did this and
in the book they did this and I was like
yeah I wrote the book and I saw the
movie so this whole interaction is like
I don't know what to tell you you know
it's like I can't yeah speak for them
and people will email me and they're
like you've screwed up you gave it away
you know it was all for the money or
whatever and you're like I didn't have
any creative control I'm not Stephen
King or John grocer one of these guys
right you know I had this little
paperback that I got a little bit of
money to advance to put out and they
offered you know to option into
Hollywood and my answer was yes it
wasn't like let me look at page 94 of
the contract right where I'm going to
come back and say I want creative
control and I want to play The Gray Man
in the movie or whatever it's like
that's how you you don't get a movie
made well Stephen King famously didn't
like the shining yeah which is wild
right because it's Stanley Kubrick and
it's Jack Nicholson it's an amazing
movie yeah but the movie was very
different than his book in his book The
the character uh Jack it takes a long
time before he goes crazy and he starts
out sane he starts out just a troubled
former alcoholic who's trying to get his
life together and do right by his family
and he gets this opportunity to look
over this hotel and he's going to write
this book and then along the way he goes
nuts yeah that's the difference between
a book and a movie like it like I like I
like that
added stuff um I think Tom Clancy didn't
like Harrison Ford
um in the in the Jack Ryan films and I
think it was just an age thing because
in his head he was pretty literal about
you know he's he's at this stage when I
wrote this book He's a young CIA analyst
who or whatever and I think Harrison
Ford was older and I'm not 100 sure
about that it's but but I I do know that
you know our bread places he Tom never
told me this but that um that he wasn't
a big fan of those and I think those are
the best ones I don't know
any of his what what ones where's
Patriot Games clear and present danger
and those were all Harrison Ford yeah
yeah no kidding yeah yeah and I think he
did a good they did they did a great job
Alec Baldwin was great in Red October
yeah and too bad he didn't stick with it
I forgot about Red October yeah yeah I
forgot about Patriot Games too yeah yeah
well it's like it's so interesting when
you get a known commodity like a famous
celebrity that comes in and takes over a
role that you've created yeah
yeah I I you know I was I was happy with
Ryan Gosling like he I just as I
described The Gray Man the the look is
pretty similar and he didn't he didn't
over bake it I feel like the scenes with
the the girl and the that he's
protecting could have turned schmalty
and cheesy yeah and they didn't and I
like that in my book I like it a little
bit better because the the girl actually
has some agency in her own rescue she
does some things to help herself whereas
this one she's just sort of like
protected uh you know by By Gentry I
mean she she kind of saves the day to
some degree too
um you know you can pick little thing
the very first scene in the movie uh
Billy Bob Thornton is a CIA guy sitting
in a prison with a dude saying here's
the name of our secret CIA program and
here's what it does would you like to
join well that's how that works you know
and there's a yeah the funniest part was
that there's a scene a big action scene
in Prague takes place in Prague and gray
man is tough to a to a bench and he's
shooting bad guys and he can't get away
and there's cops and Dead Cops around
him and then the bad guys Chris Evans
sending the bad guys in from all
directions and at one point he reaches
over to this cop and pulls a frag
grenade off the guy's utility belt and
I'm like the cops and Prague carry Frags
some hardcore cops he throws it blows
something up and I'm like but it works
in the movie you know it's like nobody's
spending that much time looking at it
unless you're the idiot that wrote it